100.000 Tonnen haushaltsbatterien und
Akkus landen jedes Jahr im Müll nur jede
zweite Batterie in der EU wird recycelt
die wertvollen Materialien gehen
verloren Giftstoffe landen in der Umwelt
gleichzeitig gibt es immer mehr kleine
Gadgets wie Wearables oder Tracking
Chips die in naher Zukunft
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr aus unserem
Alltag wegzudenken sein werden und sie
alle brauchen Strom der Bedarf an
Batterien steigt also wie cool wäre es
dann wenn wir wenigstens für diese
kleinen Anwendungen Batterien herstellen
könnten die man bedenkenlos wegschmeißen
kann zum Beispiel aus Papier und Zucker
genau das hat Dr Jules Hammond mir in
einem Interview beim falling walls
science damit in Berlin vorgestellt und
ich wollte euch unbedingt davon erzählen
[Musik]
hi mein Name ist Dr Jules hi mein Name
ist Dr Jules Hammond und ich bin CEO und
Mitgründer beim Startup BFC im one
sentence erzeugt Elektrizität mit Papier
und Enzymen wir produzieren eine
umweltfreundliche und nachhaltige
Energielösung für Mikroelektronik
das Start-up wurde aus einer
französischen Uni herausgegründet und
sie entwickeln dort sogenannte
bio-enzymatische Brennstoffzellen die
ursprünglich mal für die Medizin
erfunden wurden daraus haben Sie dann
diese kleine dünne und flexible Batterie
hier entwickelt und alles was man dafür
braucht ist ein bisschen Kohlenstoff
Glukose und Enzyme sowie einfach nur
Papier Luft und ein Tropfen Wasser okay
das klingt ja schon mal mega nice aber
wie funktioniert das genau
[Musik]
wie ihr wisst haben Batterien auf der
einen Seite einen elektronenüberschuss
das ist der Minuspol bzw die Anode und
auf der anderen Seite haben Sie einen
elektronenbedarf das ist der Pluspol bzw
die Kathode verbindet man die beiden
Pole mit einem Stromkreis dann fließt
der Strom in enzymatischen
bio-brennstoffzellen entstehen die
elektrischen Pole mit Hilfe von
chemischen Reaktionen die wiederum mit
Enzymen ermöglicht werden unsere Papier
Bio Brennstoffzelle basiert auf
Zellulose und Kohlenstoff wir drucken
die kohlenstoffelektronen auf Papier und
in jeder Elektrode sind unterschiedliche
Enzyme ein Enzym verwandelt Glukose in
glukono Lacton wodurch Elektronen
freigesetzt werden und das zweite Enzym
reduziert Sauerstoff zu Wasser wenn man
diese beiden Reaktionen kombiniert
erschafft man einen Stromfluss durch den
Stromkreis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die glukosebasierte bio-brennstoffzelle
wird von internationalen
Forschungsgruppen hauptsächlich dazu
entwickelt um medizinische Implantate
wie zum Beispiel Schrittmacher
Insulinpumpen oder Sensoren mit Strom zu
versorgen der Körper selber versorgt die
Brennstoffzelle praktisch endlos mit
Glucose Wasser und Sauerstoff für die
Brennstoffzelle von BFC sind die Glukose
und die Enzyme aber in Papier
eingebettet der Sauerstoff kommt einfach
aus der Luft und die Kontaktstellen
werden mit Kohlenstoff Elektroden im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes einfach auf
das Papier gedruckt das kann man hier
eigentlich ganz gut sehen damit die
Reaktionen ablaufen können braucht man
dann noch ein ganz kleines bisschen
Wasser das haben wir Entwickler in ihrem
patentierten Flüssigkeitsreservoir
eingebaut da muss man zum Aktivieren
einmal drauf drücken und zack erzeugt
eine Brennstoffzelle aus Papier Strom
[Musik]
die Leistung der papierbatterie ist eher
klein sie liegt im milliwattbereich und
eignet sich deshalb speziell für
Anwendungen in denen man nur wenig
Leistung braucht Handys oder sogar
E-Autos wird man mit dieser Technologie
also nicht betreiben können ein Beispiel
das dr Jules Hammond mir beschrieben hat
ist dieser kleine flexible Tracker hier
dem er und sein Team auch entwickeln der
Tracker hat eine ganze Reihe von
Sensoren und Sender für z.B Bluetooth
low energy WiFi und NFC dabei ist er
genauso flexibel wie die Papier Batterie
selber man kann mit dem Tracker z.B die
Vitalfunktionen von chronisch erkrankten
oder Bewegungsprofile von Sportlerinnen
und Sportlern überwachen oder auch die
Bedingungen kontrollieren mit denen
empfindliche Nahrungsmittel oder
Medikamente verschickt werden so kann
man z.B jedes einzelne Paket mit so
einem Trecker versehen und
Unterbrechungen in der Kühlkette leicht
feststellen man könnte aber auch
herausfinden wer auf dem Versandweg das
Paket besonders grob behandelt hat
weitere Ideen drehen sich rund um das
Internet auf things und moderne
Logistikunternehmen das Interesse ist
also da besonders groß wo Abläufe
digitalisiert werden wenn ihr die
Möglichkeit haben wollt etwas schnell
und unkompliziert gegen die Klimakrise
zu unternehmen so wie zum Beispiel der
Hersteller dieser Batterie dann könnt
ihr euch jetzt den Sponsor unseres
heutigen Videos mal genauer anschauen
nämlich die Klima App die Klima App
kennt ihr vielleicht bereits sie hilft
euch dabei euren CO2 Verbrauch zu
kompensieren zusätzlich bietet sie euch
aber auch Tipps für einen nachhaltigeres
Leben an und erklärt euch wie ihr
gemeinsam mit euren Freunden etwas gegen
die Klimakrise tun könnt wenn ihr euch
die App heruntergeladen habt wird über
einige Fragen euer CO2 Fußabdruck
bemessen den ihr dann mit einem
monatlichen Betrag offsetten also
ausgleichen könnt das Geld fließt in
eine Vielzahl nachhaltiger Projekte für
mehr Umweltschutz darüber hinaus findet
ihr in der App ganze Leben
fun oder eigentlich besser Importen fact
ihr könnt in der App sogar eurem lokalen
Abgeordneten im Bundestag schreiben und
dem man so ein bisschen Feuer unterm
Hintern machen dass man mehr für den
Klimaschutz getan wird falls ihr jetzt
noch offene Fragen zur klima-app habt
dann schaut euch gerne mal in diesem
Video hier um da haben wir die App und
die Firma dahinter mal kritisch
durchleuchtet wenn ihr also jetzt etwas
gegen die Klimawandel tun wollt dann
klickt gerne auf den obersten Link unten
in der Videobeschreibung und nutzt gerne
den Code dr Watson denn damit
unterstützt ihr uns und unsere Videos
und es werden auch noch zehn extra Bäume
in eurem Namen gepflanzt die Papier
Batterie könnte eine Alternative für
diese ganzen kleinen iCarly Batterien
werden die anscheinend einfach von voll
vielen in den Müll geschmissen werden
schon in den nächsten zwei Jahren soll
die Bio Brennstoffzelle erst für Firmen
und dann auch für Privatanwender zu
haben sein Schulz stellt sich vor das
Hobby Entwickler noch viele weitere
kreative Anwendungen finden werden
ähnlich wie z.B beim Raspberry Pi cool
finde ich auf jeden Fall dass man die
Batterie am Ende einfach wirklich guten
Gewissens wegschmeißen kann einfach weil
die gefährlichen oder umweltschädlichen
Elemente verbaut sind und ich bin schon
mega gespannt was daraus noch wird wie
immer vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric
VFC sei FC
sei der FC Kölle